I'm just curious you know if you're Bel
muhamad and Leon Edwards what's the
hesitation there why isn't that being
announced for you that's a shoe in for
300 Izzy's also going to be in town in
Toronto um this Saturday sitting
ringside not Hamot so that should be
noted as well and I know Strickland
would be down you know so if Strickland
wins I would I would assume he get Izzy
Strickland for UFC 300 that would be a
big fight that would do it or if
Strickland wins you get Strickland you
know if he wins he's not injured you get
Strickland hamzat maybe but something's
going on with Leon Edwards blah Muhammad
how how have they not announced that
theyve announced all these big fights
there's nothing there's no Rumblings
isn't that weird